late last night as the very left
Portsmouth for France the atmosphere was
almost festive this konstantina player
had voted to remain and the polls were
showing a lead for his side we need to
be more do dat PMF anything it wasn't
broken pot we had so does not need to
try to fix it I'll take whatever comes
but I voted out how do you feel by the
EU referendum coming to an end thank God
it's all over let's just get on with
life what a difference a night makes
before we arrived in can northern France
we had the result the ferry dots and
other set of passengers boarded those
returning to the UK were heading to a
very different country I will be void
out of week yeah yeah it's a look at
this point and friendship him I don't
know I I just think it's a mistake you
know what I mean hey I can't afford to
go back in no there's no turning back
that's it we're done well I wasn't
really into it until today and I've been
up my phone and haven't learned googling
everything and I am yeah quite excited
but I don't know there's a good thing or
a bad thing the waters here will come as
we left Europe Tom cheshire Sky News in
the English Channel